What do you recommend to combat night sweats?
Some evenings I have to change my shirt anywhere from one to three times. Thank you. So
Again, you're looking for the cause. What is the cause? Right? So you don't you know, we are that's all we're looking for
What's the cause of the symptom? We have a symptom. Okay. Well, this person builds with the causes
The person who asked this has a lymphoma which causes night sweats
Not all cancers do that
There isn't anything
If person knows the cause lymphoma, there really isn't anything to combat the night sweats
Adeptogens can work because part of the thought because
Understand night sweats with lymphoma. It isn't fully understood why that takes place because you don't get night sweats with a lot of other cancers
You don't get night sweats
So, but it's common with lymphoma
It's thought that it's causing an
Estrogen progesterone androgen fluctuation. That's one theory if that is true, then adaptogens could be a help
I've had people you do with lymphoma take adaptogens
It was you know, nobody has said oh my gosh, it's just made a hundred percent difference. Nobody said that
But nobody said nothing makes a hundred percent difference with night sweats
I've had people say that they've had some change. They thought that it was better with that
So consider using some adaptogenic herbs
What are adaptogenic herbs to get more specific?
We have a product called
Court of clear that would be the best adaptogenic herb for night sweats because it helps decrease cortisol
Um, but we also have we have about 10 adaptogenic products
So their adaptogenic herbs are our court of steps a holy basil
Elutero
There's just a whole bunch of different herbs that fit into that category and
um
There's a bunch of different lands out there that because of that. So
Different lands work for different people. So um, but I would think more night sweats if I was going to use an adaptogen
I would try court of clear and I would take a couple
In our half hour before bed